a sólo tres semanas de las elecciones el
presidente trump está a la defensiva en
los estados claves para la campaña
tratando de revivir su coalición de 2016
en pensilvania donde necesita aumentar
el apoyo de los votantes
el presidente desprecio a su rival
demócrata joe biden como peón de
comunistas que cerró las fábricas
[Aplausos]
uno de los asuntos más importantes para
pensilvania es la supervivencia de su
industria de fracking joe biden ha
prometido repetidamente abolir el frac
knicks es un mentiroso vale es un
mentiroso bailén las encerrara quieren
cerrar los al igual que su gobernador
les tiene encerrados ahora mismo será
mejor que abra su estado
el coronavirus fue apenas mencionado
igualmente o incluso más importante en
los comicios que pensilvania florida es
un estado considerado campo de batalla y
triunfo grande en 2016 pero esta vez las
encuestas favorecen a bailén en ese
estado el candidato demócrata mantuvo un
evento mucho más reducido en
concordancia con la campaña de bajo
perfil que mantiene esta es la elección
más importante de nuestras vidas usted
puede hacer toda la diferencia aquí en
florida puede determinar el resultado en
esta elección bien ganamos florida y se
acabó
[Música]
el candidato demócrata también cortejo a
los adultos mayores diciéndoles que
trump nunca ha estado enfocado en ellos
mientras que tram se burló de él en su
cuenta de twitter al publicar un
fotomontaje donde aparece baiden en una
silla de ruedas dentro de un lugar de
retiro una victoria de baile en sobre 30
en florida pondría en serio peligro las
posibilidades de reelección del
presidente las últimas encuestas
muestran que el demócrata va a la cabeza
en el estado